[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous nous sommes quittés au moment où le
jeune coq en retard comme toujours
lancer un cocorico timide malgré sa
timidité le cocorico réveilla le fermier
qui regarde à l'heure et d'émotions
failli tomber de son livre comment notre
coq chante avec près de 20 minutes de
retard
ah bah alors ça qu on peut voir
confiance et le fermier sort de chez lui
forte en colère il se dirige vers le
poulailler
[Musique]
hahaha
elle
dames ou acquis le vieux coq bon suis là
au moins il était un bon et fidèle
serviteur il savait maintenir l'ordre
dans le poulailler mai mais où et ide
ont alors personne ne sait ce qui se
passe chez moi
oooh seule la petite saisies aux
répondre mais peut pas on ne l'a plus
revu depuis longtemps tiens depuis que
mon bracelet a disparu étrange étrange
[Musique]
et
à
pas le faire bien à l'âme et du taux
pour s'apercevoir que joe avait disparu
c'est pas comme nous nous on l'a vu tout
de suite
au fait on devrait demander à madame
pipi je suis sûr qu'à la des nouvelles
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont ces poules à
caqueter comme ça elles sont trop
excités et aussi trop nombreuses
tiens donc on va fêter le bracelet on a
une bonne poule au pot robert herbin
attrape la plus grosse celle qui crie le
plus fort ta mère va la préparer pour le
dîner tiens voilà deux mois
voilà ce que c'est que de crier toujours
te faire remarquer il faut jouer comme
tout cela jo qu'il ne sait rien le
pauvre
[Musique]
et madame l'api que faites vous là
comment saviez-vous jetait le voyons une
jauge c'est tout moi le matin gens
trouveront ma porte et j'écoute les
nouvelles et quelles sont les dernières
nouvelles et à la ferme
que se passe-t-il dont on a retrouvé le
bracelet non c'est pas possible
chers petits bracelets dire que c'est à
cause de lui que j'ai pu m'enfuir et
qu'il a pris je me suis souvent demandé
y que donneriez-vous pour le savoir rien
je n'ai rien même plus ma canne et bien
c'est cette petite synthe de blanchette
aux adorables petites blanchette aux
quins l'histoire et la colère du fermier
[Musique]
m
adieu
et
tél